yourself are you somebody who believes
in god
well i'm looking at the sky and i'm
saying to myself that's the fabric of
god
do you think there was a creator like a
creator
that put all this together you know well
i mean uh that creator is still creating
and that creator is the cosmos and you
are
part of the cosmos so at the deepest
level
you're an aspect of god
but the god of the christians and the
islam and judaism is too small
it's too vindictive it's too human
you know you read in the bible that um
we are made in the image of god
the reality i believe is that
christians have created they've they've
it it's their imagination of what it is
and i think that's wonderful
but it is too human it's it's too
vindictive it wants to punish you if you
do something wrong
and so forth there's nothing about
learning except to obey obey obey obey
now for you know ten thousand years
uh saturn in the sky was considered to
be
um the further style planes you could
see with the naked eye in those 10
000 years these kinds of authoritarian
points of view
whether it's religion spirituality
or politics it's a top down the best
example is the pharaoh
people in those days lived hardly ever
past 40 45 in
ancient by that time and the pharaoh was
supposed to be a god that fell
from the sky to help humanity and
humanity in return was supposed to
provide him a trip back to the sky
well that's what the pyramid was for and
people
were dedicated to building that pyramid
for
when the pharaoh pharaoh dies puts in
the sarcophagus in the king's chamber
there is a shaft of light that comes
from an opening that's
treated replaced where a certain star in
some cases you know could be deneb or
any
other kind of star but this specific
star that was supposed to then hit that
sarcophagus and bring the pharaoh back
to
his position as a star in the cosmos so
we have all kinds of ideas and fantasies
and i
uh stories about why we're hearing what
we're supposed to do
so what i found in astrology is that's
the closest thing i've
ever seen that explains how god works
so i look i look at uh i look at the the
pattern
of uh the solar system the
the spiritual dna and each of these
planets you know have a specific
function
you know um mercury for instance oh
i want to go back just for a moment to
what you said about all these cancers
you have
you know why you have them why they have
this powerful thing called
image making power imagination there are
bonkers on the inside you never know
what you're going to come up with
but god sometimes the stuff that comes
up boy
you monetize that in an instant boom
there it is
you don't have to go through development
cancer
is ruled by the moon and the moon is the
development the internals
process of developing who you are so
these guys are
are really always popping out something
that could grow
you know and some of it needs more
watering than others they're nurturers
they will take care of each other
they'll take care of anybody's working
with them
uh they'll find great uh people in
in that respect so going back to what
you just said because
you just took me to hold it from the
conversation i got a bunch of other
things i want to follow up on
but uh so so do do you tie yourself to a
denomination just are you would you say
you know i consider myself
non-denomination atheist
agnostic catholic or no i i
i believe more in the zodiac than i
believe in a god
well i i i believe in the zodiac
and i am a buddhist okay okay so
and by the way i always say if i wasn't
a christian i'd be a buddhist so if you
like this sort of short club from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you